I was unaware of this singing career
that you put out an album at one point
in your in your life but did you ever
consider singing as a career I don't
mean you know maybe maybe even not being
an actor because this is video and I
know how many people have seen on the
internet but it blew my mind when you
get up with sting I don't know where
this happened you saying driven to tears
right yes how did that come about and
where was this it was his birthday and
rather than having a party he wanted to
do a fundraiser for I think the beacon
right so we got a bunch of people
together and he knows that I can sing
but he needed to rehearse me okay but
that's what I want to is he knew how
does he know you can sing to hide he
heard your album I mean I'm not he and
Trudy and I and Susan are all pretty
close and no kidding for for some time
yeah like you'll go over their house and
hang matter-of-fact Trudy sent over some
balloons and flowers for the kids and
mrs. no kidding
yeah that's right is that the best part
and he did you ever privately sing with
him is that how he knew you could sing
in other words you're hanging out I'm
gonna tell you the whole story
great all right that's what I want when
I was in my mid-20s I fancied I I
decided I was one of the great
songwriters of all time and I had this
trippy little cassette tape of all my
demos that were just not good right and
I went to one of sting shows and I had
like I accosted him in like the the
stairwell and I started trying to push
my cassette tape in his hands great and
he did what I do to people now I make
sure that that's all that's in their
hand and then I take it and I like hand
it to somebody who puts it in a box that
you never see again and right Trudy was
there recognized me maybe from like I
don't know less than zero something was
like thanks for coming to the show right
and she handled you you totally handled
me and made up for the fact that he kind
of looked at me a little bit like just
don't hand me things and kept walking so
and you feel like such a douche right
because I also had a little scarab on it
because he and I understood
synchronicity and Carl young I mean he
must it was literally it was a psychotic
moon you were stalkerish
yeah okay but you wanted to get your
music heard by Sting only only yes cuz
he would understand right I'd be opening
for him in two weeks right once we
finished the demo once he heard the tape
yeah I mean look a couple of them had
promised but let me you know have you
heard of those no those so now that were
made it so about 25 years later yeah
Trudy goes through some things old boxes
an old man we found would you like this
cassette tape back oh give me that tape
back found the tape yeah well if they if
they played it they rewound it and put
it back in the box and a tape thank God
and so when it becomes known to sting
that you can sing and he has a birthday
party he says I want you to come up now
I would think I don't with you I sense
you're never nervous in any of these
showbiz situations you're very
comfortable getting on a stage and
performing I saw you make a speech at my
birthday show you were comfortable I see
you know even in these Iron Man movies
and any movie I've ever seen you and you
seem loose as a goose
seems that way yeah were you nervous
when you have to go perform in front of
a real audience
Sting's audience and sing his song I was
nervous but right before I walked in
here because I watched the show all the
time and listened the show and I don't
believe that
all right you don't look nervous okay
good isn't that an art in and of itself
is not appearing the way you're feeling
if I appeared the way I felt all the
time I would be I'd be in a loony bin
but but wait a second so finish this
with sting yeah I'm gonna play this you
got to hear this
okay this is driven to tears this was a
great [ __ ] performance listen who
says it's just
[Applause]
[Music]
my reaction
[Music]
[Applause]
and all the Rockstar I mean I don't how
many times this clip has been viewed but
I've watched it several times sting or
people who know how to really perform
and include other people though often
let the other person shine let the other
person shine back him up right there is
he is a practically perfect performer in
every way is that it's prefer you to do
or you or is it just another day in the
life of Robert Downey jr. that was very
exciting so when you put out a album
what was it called the futurist right
that was a serious attempt at a musical
career so you gave it some thought
I get some thought I also had I had I
had free time because I wasn't all that
sought after not that was during the
years you weren't acting that much
that's right right but the lean years
very diplomatic well yeah I mean
seriously it's true and and so you said
okay I'll put out an album see what
happens yeah yeah and that didn't happen
but you can't sing thanks Harry why
don't we start a band oh don't [ __ ]
around with you in the you know super
super girl if you're not kidding we can
light the world a fire oh my god do you
realize how many people would buy
tickets for that
you